foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday January 26th I'm Zoe Thomas for
the Wall Street Journal
the tech industry has been hit hard by
layoffs for those keeping track more
than 200 000 roles have been cut intact
since the start of 2022. according to
layoffs.fyi a website that tracks the
cuts among those making large staff
reductions are Google parent alphabet
Microsoft and meta notably not on that
list
Apple so what has kept the iPhone maker
from announcing layoffs and will it be
able to keep bucking that trend
joining me to talk about this is our
Apple reporter Aaron Tilley hi Aaron
thanks for joining me hey thanks for
having me a lot of other tech companies
scaled up during the pandemic adding you
know more people to their head counts
and they're now having to rethink those
Staffing numbers in the face of some
changing economic conditions is Apple in
the same boat no Apple's not in the same
boat throughout the pandemic for the
past three years pretty much all the big
Tech players really escalated their
Workforce grew it by quite a bit except
apple apple was really conservative and
it's Workforce growth it grew about 20
percent over the past three years while
other companies like Amazon doubled
Microsoft 50 alphabet 57 and meta also
around doubling their Workforce why
didn't Apple grow at that same pace
well Apple has always been much more of
a leaner company than the rest of tech
they're very conservative they try to
make the most out of what they currently
have you know the last actual real set
of mass layoffs happen back in 1997 when
Steve Jobs returned to the company as
enough to save the company that was
under a lot of pressure so throughout
the history they've just been slowly but
steadily growing but always been very
lean Lee run is there something about
Apple's business model that has made it
more resilient then than some of these
other companies well I think a lot of
these other companies have been a lot
more vulnerable to shifts in the economy
during the height of the pandemic their
businesses really accelerated but coming
out of it they've hit some snags they've
hit some troubles you know especially in
the digital ad markets e-commerce those
have slowed down quite a bit some of
that slow down in the digital ad markets
has been due to changes Apple has made
actually so uh Apple's partially the
cause of that slowdown but also there's
this broader slowdowns economically
happening and with Apple's business the
iPhone still Reigns Supreme it is still
around 50 percent of their business and
demand really hasn't subsided that much
the big trouble for them is making
enough and there's certainly a lot of
troubles there in manufacturing these
phones you mentioned Apple running kind
of a lean business when it comes to
Staffing I mean are there other ways
that they run the business that have
kind of helped keep them on track to
avoid some of the job Cuts other
companies are having to make
well the main thing is how conservative
they grew their Workforce you know
there's all sorts of little other things
on top they don't offer free lunches
unlike a lot of the other Tech players
it's not huge but it's interesting and I
think symbolic of Apple's leanness other
Tech Giants also don't offer free lunch
but companies like alphabet and meta
they are kind of famous for their
employee perks and apple just never did
that what about in terms of investing in
other products I mean not only did a lot
of big tech companies add body counts
they also added new projects during the
pandemic kind of thinking these good
times would roll did Apple follow any of
that model yeah so uh meta and alphabet
are also famous for these really
ambitious projects that will probably
never pan out in terms of making real
business out of them Apple has some
ambitious projects itself that are
certainly risky such as a AR VR our
headset supposed to come out later this
year and they're trying to build their
own car it's really uncertain when
that'll come out but these projects that
apple is building out
there is a rationale there is a I think
fundamental business plan in place they
are trying to execute on
La is reporting its earnings next week
what do we expect from that well Apple
just went through its holiday quarter
with its brand new iPhone
14s and the thing that happened in this
previous cycle was that
manufacturing just went crazy for them
China were Apple manufacturers pretty
much all of its phones really had some
issues with its zero coveted policies
their most important facilities iPhone
City hundreds of thousands of workers
shut down over some of these zero
coveted policies or protests and riots
and Manufacturing really slowed down for
them that the wait times reached the
highest that they've ever seen for a new
iPhone launch and so what we're gonna
see I think is some disappointment in
the numbers analysts though are
expecting some of that demand to be
pushed out to the March quarter so
there's not a whole lot of concern from
Wall Street now they've tempered their
expectations but it doesn't mean
demand's gone for the iPhone it's just
Apple has to get the trains running on
time and get their manufacturing back up
to speed so we don't expect investors to
turn around and say this isn't the rosy
picture we were after why don't you make
Cuts like everyone else
no I think they understand what's on the
rise and what's coming next week but
we'll have to see how bad these
manufacturing issues hit Apple if it's
surprising if it's much worse than what
everyone all the analysts are expecting
I think there could be a chance that
there would be questions around layoffs
at Apple and should Apple be doing that
too but we'll have to wait and see how
bad this manufacturing hiccup hit Apple
all right that was our reporter Aaron
Tilley Aaron thanks so much for joining
us yeah thanks for having me and that's
it for today's Tech news briefing for
more Tech stories check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]